an SG-1 Revival a return of the series
that we really really love
this could be huge welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so I have actually been talking to some
of the people that I know that work in
and around MGM and Amazon who give me
great Intel on what's going on around
this and the rumor is and I have to say
this is firmly in the category of rumor
that actually the plan is for this
Stargate SG-1 Revival rather than a
reboot now this has been whispered about
for quite some time now but those
whispers are slowly becoming a bit more
of a shout and I'm hearing more and more
this is the way they plan to go so we
might actually get an sg1 movie followed
by a series a proper Revival of Stargate
rather than just a reboot so first of
all very quickly what's the difference
say they did a series called Stargate
command which is actually the series we
suggested they did several months ago
and we sort of did a string of video
suggesting what a new series could look
like
say they did that that would be a reboot
it would be a what they call a soft
reboot so the universe of Stargate sg1
is to USGA still exist but you have new
characters new plots new storylines and
um new actors so it's a soft reboot you
can then have a hard reboot now a
software ebook is also a lot of the
times called a continuation
you can then also though have a hard
reboot which is basically you ignore
what happened in sg1sgu SGA and you just
have a new Stargate series the Canon
previously doesn't exist so you can do
whatever you want with a new storyline
now there is a lot actually to say for
that option because by the end of
Stargate sg1 in particular the Towery
were very powerful we have Starships
zipping all over the place we're
actually the baddest Fleet in the Galaxy
so
if you have a new series you have to
start there and it's a little bit more
like Star Trek than Star Gate really so
I can understand the argument for that
but it's not what I want I don't want
sg1 SGU and SGA to be ignored I love
those series and I want a continuation
so a Revival though is a little bit
different just to a soft reboot in that
the series won't be called Stargate
something it will be called Stargate sg1
and it will actually be a Revival of
that series
it would be as if that series never
ended now in the past this was something
we very rarely get to see if a series
ended it ended that was it it very very
rarely returned and if it did it was
always sort of like a reboot but in
recent years we've actually seen it a
couple of times I've just started
watching um Criminal Minds Evolution
that is a Revival they've brought the
old actors back it's basically like the
show never ended
we've got we have seen that a couple of
other times especially with sort of like
Will and Grace and a couple of other
examples
so does this mean they will bring back
all of the old actors well they'll bring
back as many of the actors as they could
is what I'm being told and actually it
looks like they're going to try to bring
back actors from not just sg1 but SGU
and SGA I've been able to tell you
actually that Robert Carlyle has already
been approached and apparently according
to my sources so is David blue
I'm told again that Amanda Tapping would
be very willing to return and so would
Michael Shanks so we're getting at least
those four actors I would be very
surprised if Christopher Judge wasn't
willing to return and I think there are
lots of other peripheral actors people
like Joe Flanagan would you know return
in a heartbeat
so I actually think we could cherry pick
the best actors from all three of those
seasons and sort of make a superstar
gate you know characters that we love
from all three seasons together in one
new adventure now that would be based
around sg1 so I guess again we would get
to see a new team so what I am
suspecting here now this is just my
opinion but it is kind of the vibe I'm
getting from the sources I speak to that
this would be a core set of new actors
um that would be the sg1 team but the
way the story will be is that these
other actors in the peripheral will also
be heavily involved so I mean it
wouldn't be difficult for like General
Carter to be sort of like the head of
the new SGC to take on the Hammond role
it wouldn't be difficult to bring
Michael Shanks into some sort of
Civilian leader or potentially even the
maybe the leader of the new SG-1 team
I'd like to see that
um or Joe Flanagan as the leader of the
sg1 team or so on and so on Ben Browder
Maybe
so that would basically be the way the
new SG-1 series will be based it will
have a core of new actors
but with surrounding of a lot of
returning actors now I don't know about
you guys but I really am interested by
that idea I like the idea of us being
introduced to somebody new you know I
want that next interesting character and
actually the people that brought us sg1
in the past were really good at that and
I actually think that the Creator's
penguin and a Parker I I trust them to
create an interesting new core
characters for this series but then to
bring back as many of the old characters
as possible is again also it just it'll
it'll make us feel at home it will make
the series feel like Stargate we will
know the characters we will feel an
instant sort of connection to the series
that if they just do a straight up soft
reboot will be more difficult to get
if you think about the difference
between Star Trek the Original Series
and Star Trek the Next Generation we
fell in love with those characters but
initially they had to work really hard
to get us hooked if you bring back a few
of the original characters for Stargate
will already be hooked and as I say
We'll already feel at home but also I
have been seriously concerned about how
they would set up this series
Stargate I was worried it would become
more like Star Trek than Stargate as
I've said
so to revive the SG-1 series to call it
that for one is fine with me I don't
mind but to revive the basic premise of
a team going through the gate going on
adventures monster of the week kind of
thing
that just makes sense to me and it's the
sort of television series we want to see
now Stargate Universe
it was limited in lots of ways for me
even though I thought it was getting
loads better
it was limited in the fact that they
were stuck in one place now I know they
did go on planets when it stopped every
so often but it didn't have the scope
that sg1 had sg1 could literally do
anything week on week because they were
going to completely different places
week on week Stargate Universe was a lot
more about them surviving and then
trying to you know discover the
mysteries of the destiny
now I don't have any problem with that
sort of series I quite enjoy them if you
have the Star Trek if you think about
that similarly T and G they could go
anywhere do anything Deep Space Nine not
so much because they were stuck on the
base until the defiant came along and
then the egg had a bit more scope
Voyager even even though they did do
anything each week there was always that
limitation in that they were trying to
get home there was no Federation there
was no support so you know again they
were kind of limited in what they could
do so if they bring back Stargate sg1 it
basically allows them to do anything
and that's something I'd be really
excited to watch
the other thing is
there does seem to be a thing in
Hollywood that Hollywood Executives and
stuff have actually suddenly in the last
few years remembered that we quite like
that kind of thing
we do like the monster of the week show
again if we look at new Trek they
brought us Discovery a very limited in
scope based around one ship it was that
overarching story
um even though it was quite interesting
places there was always that limitation
in that they were focused around one
story arc but then we've had strange new
worlds now I think it's fair to say the
fans have reacted far more warmly to
Strange New worlds than they did to
Discovery now we're all very excited
about Picard but seasons one and two
were again limited by that one
overarching story
the audience enjoy that kind of thing
but it's not what we want all the time
we do enjoy the monster of the week kind
of thing as well and Hollywood
Executives seem to have remembered that
recently
so again this is another hint that
actually MGM and Amazon are listening to
us and if this is the way they go and
they revive sg1 I genuinely think
they're going to create a series that
takes us straight back to the very heady
early days of Stargate sg1 there we will
get you know story arcs throughout it we
will get villains that
um you know we see week in week out but
we'll also get to see loads of new
planets that look suspiciously like
Canadian forests and we'll get to see
new villains we've never heard of before
and that's pretty exciting as well as
getting characters that we know and love
and new characters to fall in love with
so guys get in the comments and tell me
what you think is this monster of the
week sg1 Revival something that you'd be
excited about or is it something that
you're like yeah been there done that
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and you can also go and join us on
patreon where for a small fee you get to
watch most of our videos without
trailers and before YouTube so if you
want to see our videos before everyone
else you need to go over to patreon
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]